I do is you want to put your complex
numbers into the trigonometric form
which we talked about in a previous
video but when you multiply the two
complex numbers represented here by z1
and z2 what you do is you multiply the R
values and you add the angles but when
you divide you divide the R values and
you subtract the angles now additions
commutative but subtraction is not
commutative so you want to be careful
when you're dividing if you're dividing
Z 1 by Z 2 you want to make sure that r1
is in the numerator are choosing the
denominator and that the angle of the
first complex number is subtracting the
angle of the second complex number so
that order is important so let's take a
look at a couple examples say we want to
multiply these two complex numbers
together we're going to multiply the R
values so that's 8 and we're going to
add the angles so that's going to give
you cosine of 90 plus I sine of 90
degrees now if you want to simplify this
cosine of 90 is 0 sine of 90 is 1 so
that's just going to give you I and if
you distribute this 8 you get 8 times 0
0 so you just get a tie so that's how
you can switch back from the
trigonometric form back to the standard
form so all we do is multiply the R
values and add the angles now if you
want to divide Z 1 by Z 2 now we're
going to divide so we've got 4 divided
by 2 which is 260 minus 30 which is 30
so we have 2 cosine 30 plus I sine 30
and if we want to simplify cosine of 30
is square root 3 over 2 and sine of 30
is 1/2 and so by distributing this 2 we
get square root of 3 plus I and so
that's back into the standard form so
dividing you want to just take the Z 1
divided by Z 2 and then you want to
subtract the angles so this has been how
to work with multiplying and dividing
complex number
I'll see you in the next video